[Music]
so we are here just chilling with the
truth about the Hangout and see see what
comes to us II was gonna bring that that
appetite let the plants speak to you
are you edible probably not bring that
flavor that's pizzazz it's about cutting
ports my knife and on to the frying pan
because I feel like I'm just making the
same [ __ ] how do I cook from the heart
it's where I come out man sometimes you
just gotta go out to the ocean and spell
out this beautiful ocean breeze like
people get hyped up Elaine they talk
about how wonderful it is how dope the
city life is for me I'm more of a nature
type of person these rocks are sharp
dude
[ __ ] nature touch of plants probably
some [ __ ] that I shouldn't touch see the
rock look at the ocean waves is here a
crash listen to that [ __ ]
that's God speaking to me he's telling
me I'm beautiful the ocean to an Asian
person is basically a free supermarket
look at this cute little family behind
us you feel like you don't beat you kids
we're a very specific reason I didn't
want to bring these two refugees out
here to remind them of a homeland so
much they forgot that we're out here
doing the shoot and look at them they're
only out here trying to click lunch I
bet they're gonna come back with six
fish for crabs and a pot of soup
the secret ingredient is here somewhere
let me touch the water real quick
right here
I found it
spare
whoa
I killed a fly [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways inspiration came to me in a can
of spam this is not a sponsored video
but I will say this if you don't like
spam clearly you're not Hawaiian clearly
you're not Asian I don't know what's in
this stuff but it's [ __ ] delicious we
are going to be making spam musubi not
musubi musubi Hawaiian people gave me
[ __ ] for that what are we gonna start
with my friends we are gonna get a pan
hot El Chapo this right here is like
spam I like light spam because we are
going to be using a soy glaze with this
already so salt on top of salt we don't
really need that
go light spam when you're cooking spam
too by the way I see a lot of people
they just kind of heat it all the way
through and they think it's done no you
want color here the spam sing to you
nobody knows what you're made of or
what's inside of you
while the spam is cooking we are gonna
be working on the soy glaze get yourself
a pot and make sure you turn on the
right [ __ ] stove that's the seventh
time I've done that equal parts oi sauce
two equal parts [ __ ] where is it brown
sugar well this is a quarter cup we need
one more we are going to take your
Meereen which is rice seasoning [ __ ] now
I say roughly about a tablespoon or two
stir around a little bit get a little
sexy in there holla spam is done no this
is just the basic sauce at this point
honestly you could add whatever flavor
that you want to it but just a little
mirin just a little soy sauce just a
little brown sugar what I actually like
to do is add just a little bit of rice
vinegar to break up that saltiness and
that sweetness that's up to you know
that's preference my friends you don't
let anybody tell you what to do with
your damn sauce if they do this stab
them right in the throat you need
yourself a spam musubi maker such as
this take the rice
put it in the bottom take your spam
that's a golden [ __ ] it up and you're
gonna put it in the sauce like so and
boom boom boom boom
all up in my zoom zoom put your spam
piece right there
take your musubi here take it all the
way to the other side and there you have
it my friends a spam musubi [ __ ]
delicious don't wanna go home about
sweet savory salty rice eat delicious so
let me show you my breakfast spam musubi
get your eggs ready unsalted preferred
because if I need to add salt I'll just
out of my fluffy so you ain't gonna tell
me how to add my [ __ ] salt I'm
an independent woman man then that
butter goes take your egg crack them in
you could obviously scramble it a little
bit ahead of time just to get it going
but it's gonna be quick doesn't have to
be perfect perfection is overrated my
friends take your little soft spatula
break up those yolks and just mix it in
right here
all chef [ __ ] in your face let it cook
on one side flip it let it go to the
other side and there you have it take
your eggs nonstick pan slide it off to
the side take your little mold chop it
there you go got some [ __ ] eggs move
it off to the side take your rise [ __ ]
that's a lot of rice press that rice
down take your spam dip it in the sauce
once again take it put it right here
done take your egg put it right there
done take your little smash o matic
press it down take your nori once again
put it right here
spam musubi the breakfast spam musubi
right there
and there you go [ __ ] well
[Music]
well
just to put it in perspective even in
nature this gang bikes you can't just
come up and just start rolling up on
somebody's area and set but I'll ask you
permission these two is careful to hear
they duking it out for this [ __ ]
disrespectful as hell and just be
rolling up on his rock like that yo
and now catch the camera